il ya deux ans presque jour pour jour
j'ai pris une décision faire
l'expérience de la déconnexion numérique
à new york pendant 90 jours sans
internet sans ordinateur et son
téléphone portable
j'ai envie de vous raconter mon histoire
la technologie elle nous connecte elle
nous permet de dire des choses mais
qu'est ce qu'elle dit de nous ses
utilisateurs ses créateurs
je trouve amusante cette curiosité qu'on
a pour la technologie vous savez on la
regarde on la prend en photo on la teste
on l'as cannes on adore ses spécificités
techniques
son design on est émerveillé devant
cette technologie pourtant on peut lui
reprocher son hyper connexion sa
présence son omniprésence au quotidien
dans notre vie moi je crois que la
technologie c'est un outil alors
pourquoi le faire ce reproche après tout
c'est un outil j'ai ma responsabilité
est engagée dans son usage ya plein de
choses qui m'agacent avant de partir
j'en ai marre de pas comprendre toujours
mes interlocuteurs
j'en ai marre de mal interpréter le
message fort heureusement depuis on a
inventé le smiley vous savez le sma
laisser le petit bonhomme jaune qui vit
des choses comme ça j'aurai savez ce
type de trucs ça dit beaucoup de choses
en fait
mais ce n'est pas tout tout le non
verbal ne transparaît pas alors j'ai eu
envie de quitter ce monde là j'ai eu
envie de reconnecter avec plus de
spontanéité plus d'authenticité plus de
naturel
j'ai envie d'entrer en contact direct
avec les gens sans passer par autre
chose sans passer par du plastique
et puis je m'interroge aussi sur
l'influencé de la technologie dans ma
vie l'impact du virtuel sans le réel et
puis je me demande finalement est ce que
je fais dépendant de mon téléphone
new york new york
c'est d'abord un rêve de gosse j'ai
toujours voulu vivre quelque chose de là
bas j'ai toujours voulu sentir les
vibrations la vitesse tout va très vite
il ya un monde pas possible et lumière
une énergie et vous savez cette énergie
là qui est motrice aussi de cette
technologie
comment est ce que je vais ressentir
cette énergie c'est la question que je
me suis posée j'arrive à new york jets
de déficit en arrivant
le premier s'est trouvé un appartement
comment vous faites vous pour trouver un
appartement ou pour chercher un
appartement internet met d'accord
comment vous faites sans internet moi je
n'avais pas non plus j'avais rien
anticipé dans cette expérience
je me suis juste dit je vais les
regarder dans l'est dans les journaux
voire des petites annonces etc et je me
suis rendu compte que parce que j'ai new
york c'était compliqué de trouver des
petites annonces dans le new york times
sauf si vous voulez acheter une maison à
500 mille dollars dans le connecticut
ce n'est pas vraiment le but de
l'expérience au départ alors j'ai eu
quelques petites galères je me souviens
d'une fois où j'ai traversé tous entrer
le parc de long en large en questionnant
les gens dans la rue vous savez en leur
demandant si jamais il n'y a pas une
disponibilité et quelque part non ça
marche pas comme ça il faut laisser
tomber ça ça marche pas non j'ai fait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus concret
au bout du cinquième jour je me suis
rendu au consulat de france
hélas au consulat de france je fais une
belle rencontre quelqu'un au service
social qui m'a accompagné qui m'a dit
marc au centre culturel français c'est à
trois blocs dans la peur inside face à
central park et encore des endroits sur
terre où la france a des moyens et je me
rends je me rends dans ce centre
culturel français qui est absolument
magnifique
je m'apprête à en sortir et là il se
passe un truc incroyable alors que ça
fait cinq jours que je complètement
déconnecté numériquement
il ya le visible de l'entrée qui me tend
un téléphone fixe que j'ai le droit
d'utiliser une temps le téléphone et
hindi monsieur en français
monsieur il ya quelqu'un au téléphone
pour vous hallucinant quand même c'était
cinq jours que je gamberge sur la
déconnexion numérique etc
il ya quand même un type king temps au
téléphone bon je décroche tu décroches
lots au bout du fil une femme qui me dit
oui marc antoine j'ai eu vent votre
expérience par le parc par le consulat
de france
j'aimerais vous aider je vous propose de
rencontrer stéphane heyd 7h30 à new york
à l'angle de la 53e et la 6e avenue
il est grand et parce qu'une porte une
veste beige uk super magnifique je me
suis senti dans un film d'espionnage
vous savez alors j'y vais je rencontre
ce fameux stéphane on sympathise ça
marche
voilà comment j'ai trouvé un appartement
à new york sans internet
j'ai eu un deuxième défi ensuite trouver
un appartement
ça m'a pris un peu de temps mais après
j'ai quand même près de 85 jours à
combler donc bon il faut il faut
s'activer
j'ai un visa touriste puisque jaurès 90
jours alors je peux pas travailler mais
revanche peut faire du bénévolat
jean tournoux consulat de france et là
j'ai trois contacts pour travailler
comme bénévole dans trois associations
qui sont des comptoirs alimentaires
c'est à dire des espaces qui distribuent
de la nourriture à des gens qui sont
dans le besoin
on est encore au début de l'expérience
et malgré tout j'affronte quelque chose
de nouveau
pas tant la déconnexion numérique mais
je suis en face d'une population des
gens qui sont déconnectés humainement
ces gens ont pas tant besoin de
connexion numérique virtuel ce dont ils
ont besoin c'est d'avoir l'attention de
l'autre d'avoir la présence de l'autre
essaie d'obtenir une forme de
reconnaissance aussi parce qu'ils sont
déconnectés humainement je suis touché
par sa très touché et amis expérience je
je réalise quelque chose de nouveau
je me rappelle ces mois de décembre qui
commence à faire froid new york dans mon
petit vit dans une petite chambre elle
aime et je commençais à avoir des
palpitations
je me réveille en sursaut j'ai des
sueurs froides c'est pas facile
il ya une vraie douleur quelque chose
d'inattendu pour la première fois de ma
vie je prends conscience qu'un jour je
vais mourir une connexion physique un
truc physiologique
ça sent part complètement deux mois en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que je prends
confiance qu'un jour je vais me
déconnecter un jour je vais devoir faire
face à l'ultime des connexions et à ce
moment là l'expérience prend une autre
tournure plus grave plus dramatique
on est moins dans le forez des premiers
instants j'ai la chance de pouvoir
écrire pour un journal par une
expérience le film d'anne poste qui
continue ici à écrire qui envoie du
courrier ouais pas très nombreux vous
savez le courrier pour ceux qui savent
passer les trucs qu'on reçoit entre des
factures de téléphone et des plans pour
les pizzas
oui ça existe encore des trucs là après
toute cette euphorie
je réalise que je souffre
que cette déconnexion que je vois chez
l'autre je l'aï moi même alors il faut
rentrer de l'expérience et je peux vous
assurer que je peux vous assurer d'une
chose le vrai courage c'est pas d'être
parti à new york mais c'est de rentrer
non la technologie pam a pas manqué du
tout les appareils de technologie m'ont
absolument pas manquer est assez
rapidement en fait je me suis habitué à
cette forme de non communication
alors il faut anticiper les rendez vous
bien sûr ça demande un petit peu
d'organisation et spécialement de la
confiance pour l'autre va pas se
retrouver comme ça
le texto de dernière minute pour se
retrouver d'un trottoir à l'autre ça
existe plus on fait tous n'est ce pas
alors je rentre de new york et la
pareille je suis pas bien j'ai pas bien
et je comprends pas pourquoi je suis pas
bien parce qu'après tout quand on se
déconnecte numériquement on est a priori
plus connectés avec soir ça c'était la
représentation mentale intellectuelle
que j'avais je me suis dit en le
déconnectant du téléphone tu serais plus
capable d'être concentré sur toi tu
seras plus en mesure d'apprécier
l'instant présent à bâle on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé c'est pour ça que je
souffre je souffre parce que je réalise
que j'ai jamais été autant déconnecté de
moi même et puis je fais une belle
rencontre un jour un jour d'avril
allez dans la salle une rencontre
amoureuse dans mon amour combattants
téléphonera toutes les photos que tu
fais pour installer un jeu je fais une
belle rencontre et cette belle rencontre
elle me dit quelque chose un jour de
juillet elle me dit mais mon amour ma
vie ne dépend pas de toi ma vie ne
dépend pas de toi dans ces dix mots il
ya la clusaz l'expérience de new york
dans ces dix mots il ya tout ce pour
quoi je m'interroge sur la connexion et
la déconnexion
ça parle d'amour et appareils de
dépendances
et là je comprend quelque chose de
fondamental en fait ce que je comprends
c'est que je suis tellement dépendant de
l'autre c'est patent de la technologie
dont je suis dépendant mais c'est du
regard de l'autre de ce pour quoi il
peut me satisfait c'est pourquoi me
rassure sur ma propre existence
c'est ça que ça dit en fait cet hyper
connexion que je vis cette difficulté
que j'ai à interagir avec les gens par
le biais du téléphone parce qu'à une
pression énorme
j'attends de l'autre qu'il me rassure
sur qui je suis j'attends que d'autres
j'attends de l'autre qu'ils m'aiment
parce que je suis incapable de le faire
pour moi voilà ce que ça dit alors
j'aimerais tenter une petite expérience
avec vous je vais vous présenter mon
invité s'est monté dicks berre et j'ai
envie de m'y mets quelque chose qu'est
ce qu'il dit ce tedx berre il faut bien
plus fort il faut dire plus fort ok tout
le monde dit le dites le merci c'est
exactement ça cet instant l'acte de plus
pour moi c'est génial reste exactement
ça ce qui se passe sur facebook quand je
change de statut c'est ça quand je
change de statut sur facebook
je vous envoie un tel iceberg est ce que
j'attends de vous c'est que vous me
disiez que vous m'aimez pas je peux
avoir mon coûte cher quand même ok je
terminerais là dessus
le plus important dans cette expérience
c'est de comprendre ma responsabilité
dans mon usage de la technologie c'est
de comprendre aussi la nécessité d'être
autonome de ma capacité à me donner de
l'amour et c'est comme ça que je deviens
vraiment indépendants ainsi